as students you're probably thinking
about how you can better yourself and
the kind of goals that you'd like to
accomplish in 2022
it's not too late for you to set new
goals and become better in your student
life and here we are to help you with
just that
on that note hey guys welcome to yet
another interesting video by simply
learn but before we begin if you're new
here and you haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the bell icon and
subscribe to our channel for interesting
tech videos every day
so let's get started here are 10 new
year's resolutions that every student
must incorporate
first and foremost learn something new
this is one of the best ways to start a
new year
learning a new skill can prepare you for
your future and open doors to new
possibilities or your dream job
this could end up being a great hobby
too you can run a self-introspection and
understand what subjects interest you
the most and learn something new in that
field
it could be learning a new language or
learning programming or cooking or
anything else that interests you what is
most important is being passionate about
what you're going to learn as this will
take you a long way
our second tip to you is to create a
good balance between education and life
with course deadlines to meet and trying
to enjoy your student life sometimes it
can be a little stressful and daunting
striking the right balance is crucial
hence you need to make sure what success
means to you and then create an
appropriate balance depending on your
priorities
make sure you set aside designated time
for tasks in your life this way you can
strike the right balance not to forget
the right balance is also one of the
secrets to good mental health
our third tip is to create a study
routine
study routine is something every student
has to make it's the first in achieving
a successful student life
having a pre-planned study routine will
save you from last exam tension
a well-planned study routine will help
you divide your school work into smaller
manageable daily tasks
the fourth tip is to overcome
procrastination this might be a tip that
you would have come across often however
it could have been challenging for you
to implement it in the past well this
year can be different and you could
religiously try to overcome
procrastination for a better future
nothing can be worse than delaying your
work until the last minute this will not
only hinder your productivity but also
increase your stress
hence to overcome procrastination we
would suggest you to break down your
tasks and create a timeline for them and
abide by them
use checklists start your work early and
use timers to motivate yourself
by doing this you can work towards
overcoming procrastination
remember to be consistent only then will
you be able to eliminate procrastination
completely
our fifth step to you is to not just
focus on your grades but learning on the
whole
education is best used when it is
applied to your job or everyday life
hence make sure you don't robotically
focus only on securing good grades and
rather remember to put the concepts you
learn to use in your life
by doing so you're improving your
understanding of the concept and at the
same time improving your scores without
any pressure
this way of understanding and applying
what you study will benefit you in the
long run
the next step we have is develop your
soft skills soft skills refer to various
personality traits such as communication
critical thinking time management etc
without appropriate soft skills you
cannot put your heart skills to use in
collaborative working environments soft
skills are extremely crucial in today's
world currently employers value soft
skills over hard skills hence it's
imperative that you polish your soft
skills and are fit to be hired in the
outside world having said that
communication skills are something that
you need to hone
effective communication will help you in
both your personal and professional
setting
our next tip is to be social and attend
networking events
making new friends and connections will
help you in your student life and in
your life thereafter
joining a student club is a good way to
meet new people similarly networking
events help you connect with
professionals
networking provides you with better
future opportunities needless to say you
must set up a profile at linkedin to
start your networking journey
our eighth tip to you is to back a
part-time job working and studying can
be tedious however it has its perks
and extra income is always welcome isn't
it
not only that having a part-time job on
your resume will highlight your profile
and show the employer how credible you
are
there are several jobs that are
perfectly designed for students and
those that will help you fetch some good
experience for your professional career
thereafter
so start applying for positions that
will enhance your experience in your
field of study
it could be a full-time position or an
internship that will eventually help you
our ninth step to you is to tame your
social media use
this is not as easy as it sounds social
media can get quite tricky hence
reducing your usage will allow you to
invest on other things
by doing so there will be fewer
distractions and you will be more
focused on your goals
one way of achieving this is by spending
some time on screen free hobbies like
gardening reading a book and so on
for example set a time out every day to
read
you could also read newspapers regularly
to stay informed and updated with the
latest news
our final tip to you is to save money
you might wonder if this is an important
thing being a student but the truth is
it is
as the saying goes a penny saved is a
penny earned
sometimes it can be easy to overspend
hence make sure you have a set budget
every month and control your finances
this will help you spend less and have
more money left over each month than you
did before
so with that we come to the end of this
video on top 10 2022 resolutions for
students do you agree with our list
do you think we've missed out anything
important if yes do let us know in the
comment section below
thank you so much for being here and do
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here